one of the main features of my overall
work in philosophy both my popular and
academic work and also my my general
approach is that of philosophical
eclecticism so I thought that in these
philosophical developments and
commitments videos it might be very
useful for me to talk about what what I
mean by my own eclecticism
distinguishing it from things that other
people have in mind when they say that
term and talking about why that that
works well for me and how I ended up in
that I don't say that that everybody in
philosophy should be in eclectic as a
matter of fact if you are an eclectic
you probably have a vested interest in
other people not all being eclectic
because it provides you with the raw
material that you could say you are
drawing upon and sampling and
synthesizing into something that that
works for you but I I am you know
philosophically an eclectic I'm somebody
who wears many hats a lot of viewers in
watching me are surprised to you know
see when I do a Nietzsche video that I
seem to be a Nietzschean when I do a
video on st. Thomas Aquinas they think
I'm at Ulmus when I do a video on Plato
they think I'm a plainness and that's
because I draw bits from from you know
each of them I think I you know managed
to call out what what is really valuable
and with that what are the strengths of
their their philosophy and I try to
avoid the weaknesses or the blind spots
that they have so let's talk first about
well what is this term eclectic mean I
want to say from the beginning it's an
ambiguous term right so there's multiple
meanings to it I'm not going to say that
we have to take one single meaning as
the only legitimate or even as the the
most legitimate meaning I will say that
that you know lexically it comes from
Greek as many of our philosophical terms
do Eck you know out of
and then the lectin is the drawing upon
you know you know I suppose if I was
Heidegger I could come up with all sorts
of cool etymological stuff but I'm not
going to worry about that because that's
not really what I'm when I'm interested
in I think that one sense of eclectic
that doesn't really apply to me but a
lot of people have in mind when they
they say that word or when they you know
are describing themselves or talking
about other people is somebody who just
sort of picks and chooses you know at
whim or at random whatever it is that
they like so you know you ask somebody
what kind of music are you into and they
say I have a collective taste and that
means that they sort of pick and choose
a little bit of everything I'm not
really like that in philosophy as a
matter of fact I don't even really try
at this point to like do a
representative sample you know I need
something from you know 19th century
German philosophy and I need something
from 19th century French philosophy and
something from 20th century
anglo-american analytic and some
classical American I don't do it that
way right I'm not a a person who picks
and chooses sort of on a quota system
anything like that although actually
when I when I do teach classes I try to
give a good you know representative
sample of what there is out there
there was actually a movement in in
philosophy that I should mention as well
that was called eclecticism and
associated with Victor cuisine and other
intellectuals and and they were they
were doing something a little bit closer
to what it is that I mean by eclecticism
but you know when I think of somebody
who's an eclectic one of the key
thinkers that has really grown on me
over the years and who I kind of looked
to as a model is Cicero if you ever read
Cicero's dialogues and I'm gonna shoot
one of these videos specifically about
why it is that I love Cicero so much you
know Cicero has it's almost like he's
telling a joke right an epicurean a
skeptic and a stoic walking to a bar
except in this case they're walking into
Cicero's house or they're hanging out
and they're gonna talk about you know
the nature of the gods or the way a
republic should be set up or what is the
the final good and and the worst evil
for human beings and they're you know
he's gonna set them up to talk with each
other and to present their positions and
to you know criticize other positions on
the way in very very structured
sometimes very erudite ways and then
they're gonna critique each other so
it's it's a really a genuine dialogue I
love Cicero's dialogical works and even
in his less dialogical works where he's
just presenting you know some some
theories he'll he'll draw from a number
of different thinkers and schools and
that's part of what I really like about
about that approach that eclectic
approach you got to know the
philosophical sources inside and out you
take what you find valuable from them
you perhaps strip off the elements that
you don't find valuable you have some
reason why you're doing that and that is
the approach that that I myself take in
philosophy so I probably should say
something about you know who I upon and
I'll do that very briefly here and then
I'll tell you a little bit more about it
in a bit and why I'm particularly
attracted to them so I think a lot of
people know me these days in part
because of my connections with the
modern stoic movement and being editor
of stoicism today I really do draw quite
heavily on stoicism stoicism is
something that I began researching 20
years ago and I'd say in the last 10
years I've really gotten into it in a
serious way I see it as a pretty
valuable set of conversation partners
but I'm not actually a stoic in an
Orthodox sense you know there's there's
some things about stoic philosophy that
I I don't you know completely accept and
so I don't actually call myself a stoic
although I'm fine if other people want
to tell me that I
I am similarly I draw very strongly on
the Aristotelian tradition but I'm not
really an Aristotelian although I'm you
know very Aristotelian in certain
respects I draw up on the plate in this
tradition which doesn't just include
Plato himself but also middle Platonism
with people like Plutarch Wirth's being
systematized some Neoplatonic thinkers
some of them pagans some of them I like
fuel of Alexandria I like I like some of
the Christian neoplatonist s'right
there's there's a lot of Christian
thinkers who I find quite interesting
sometimes precisely because of what
they're doing when said synthesizing
Christianity and Greek philosophy
sometimes in spite of that and you know
that takes me through the Middle Ages
you know I read and draw quite a bit
John Cassian an Augustine of Clement of
Alexandria Anselm of Canterbury Thomas
Aquinas but I don't really I still don't
belong to to any of them in the sense of
being an East right and then there's
many modern thinkers who I particularly
like there's a lot of things I really
enjoy and des cartes philosophy although
I'm not a Cartesian there's a lot of
things I think are really cool about
Leibniz and about Hume and even about
count you know I think a lot of people
know me of course because of the half
hour Hegel series and I do use Hegel I
think he's right about some things I
don't buy the overall scheme and I'm not
really think Eliot in that sense
Kierkegaard marx nietzsche you know
these are all thinkers who I really
enjoy some some things from and and draw
upon but I'm not
a member of their school so you know if
you if you wanted to say it very broadly
you could say that you know in in my my
thinking in my practice as a
philosophical counselor as a you know
consultant I draw up on the plate inist
the Aristotelian and the stoic
traditions even the sometimes the
Epicureans or the skeptics you know a
lot of Christian philosophy some of
which is much more Augustinian some of
which is more Aristotelian based you
know like an Intimus the cart you know
hobbes
hume live nets in pascal of course very
important thinker for me some of the the
the other more contemporary approaches
you know dialectical we might call it in
a certain respect deconstructive there's
some things about that I like I like the
psychoanalytic tradition or these parts
of it right
particularly Jacques Lacan I'm
interested in and Hans Cole and then
some of the the other people and you
know we can go on and on and on of the
existentialist right although they're a
mixed bag too so I draw upon all of this
stuff and you know I'm not saying that I
have like a comprehensive grasp of the
history of thought or anything like that
but I do have a pretty broad background
and I can find a lot of things that I
deem interesting or useful and like to
bring together and do comparative work
with and I think that's part of what it
means to be a philosophical eclectic it
also means that as opposed to somebody
who you know is in a particular movement
and identifies that that tradition my
work is really really really never done
there's always more to read there's
always more to think about I don't
really have a a permanent home you might
say although I'm welcome in many places
and and happily so unless you know
somebody wants to kick me out for not
being properly Orthodox
so you know what I see the the task for
myself is these days a lot of is what I
do here on YouTube there's so many
wonderful interesting thinkers whose
thoughts that I find valuable and I want
to share them with other people and then
you know when I get into two particular
counseling situations you know thinking
about particular issues then I start you
know applying this one this one this one
this one and a lot of that actually
depends on what it is that the people
that I'm talking with want to focus on
right
not everybody is into this philosopher
who I'm into so maybe I use a different
language a different thinker to reach
them and I guess the last thing that I
should talk about since you know this is
not just about philosophical commitments
but but also development how did I end
up here you know I would say that in
many respects for the good portion of my
early philosophical career I was
struggling with with two competing
desires and one of them was to get to
know as much of the the valuable
philosophy whether it's you know what we
call the history of philosophy or
whether it was contemporary stuff to get
to know as much of that stuff as I could
I mean I was just you know eating it up
and and going through as much as I could
possibly take in and loving it on the
other hand I did want to have a place
where I could I could be a tradition in
which I could locate myself a community
to which I could see myself as belonging
and very often those two kind of
conflict with each other because to be
part of a community often means
accepting a certain we might call it
party line about other philosophers and
what took place in the history of
philosophy and I never really found
a single narrative that I could really
totally buy into because I you know if
somebody would say well Aristotle did
this and this or the Christian thinkers
in the Middle Ages did this and this or
you know those pulse modernists are
doing this and this I would actually
read the figures and I'd be like wow
part of that might be true but really
that's kind of a distortion and you know
if you've read this you wouldn't say
that sort of thing wow I did read it and
well I guess you didn't really read it
carefully you kind of put the blinders
on at the start and I got a lot of
experiences like that and and so
eventually I had to get okay with being
an eclectic and I suppose what I'll
close on is something I brought up in in
some other videos so you know like I
mentioned you know people think that I'm
coming from this point of view or that
point of view or this point of view or
that point of view as if I'm you know
that's my my fundamental commitment
because I like to do justice to to the
ideas and in particular thinkers works
and I like to present them in a way that
that's coherent and is somewhat
plausible at least and so I have a lot
of people thinking that I belong to one
school or another when I when I actually
don't but I am you know very happy to be
engaged in conversation so you know when
I go to like here at Marquette every
year just down the street they have a
nice Aristotelian conference well then I
talk about Aristotle a lot and other
people in the Aristotelian tradition at
snowicon' I'm gonna talk mostly about
stoicism you know if I'm at the st.
Anselm conference probably I'll talk a
lot about st. Anselm and they're gonna
talk about Thomas Aquinas do it and some
other thinkers and so it makes perfect
sense to me that that's how I would live
my my life and make use of the remaining
years that are left to me to study and
teach and do some scholarship and you
know do some presentations and
application of philosophy so you know
I've come to be comfortable didn't it
didn't happen right away but I've come
to be comfortable with being an eclectic
with you know seeing that's where I'll
probably be for a long time I don't know
I might end up you know departing from
that and saying I'm definitely going for
this school or definitely going for that
school you never know right but that
doesn't look like what's in the cards
for me and again I don't have any
problem with other people
wholeheartedly you know saying my my you
know mind my heart my spirit belongs to
so-and-so right that's great
that's just not not where I'm going and
it makes the the dialogue the ongoing
conversation that is philosophy a lot
more fun if we do have people who are
genuinely hardcore committed I think so
that's enough about this topic be
interested to see what your comments are
and hope that this fills you in those of
you that have been asking me for these
these more personal videos about me and
and what it is that I I think and how I
do philosophy
you